字幕: 美穂 轟
校正: Yoshiaki Yamagami
私は琵琶湖が大好きです
琵琶湖のある大津市で育ちました
父 母 妹 そして祖母の
５人家族でした
父 母が働いていたので
祖母がいつも 私の面倒を見てくれました
その祖母が 私が中学生の時に
自宅で転んで 歩けなくなりました
母が仕事を辞めて
10年間自宅で介護をしました
私の家には 階段があったりしたので
車椅子の祖母を 階段で下ろす
またお風呂に入れる
私や妹が学校に行ってしまうと  母は近所の
人に助けてもらって介護をしていました
今は介護保険という制度があります
しかし 当時はそのような制度がなかった
その中で 年を取るということは
誰にでもあります
それに対して もっと 身近な行政が
できることがあるのではないか
それが 私が最初に
政治に興味を持ったきっかけでした
大学は 北海道大学に進学をしました
今は この時代は
就職氷河期と呼ばれています
男性の学生には 先輩から
就職のお誘いの連絡がありました
しかし 女性の学生には
何の連絡もありませんでした
なかなか就職するのは難しいな と思って
法学部でもあったので
司法試験の勉強を始めました
しかし 大学３年生の時 ４年生の時
さらに 留年した時も 司法試験に落ちました
ますます就職できなくなると
非常に不安に思い そして焦りました
大学を留年した年に 東京の事務所に
インターンシップに行く機会がありました
その事務所は Ｍ＆Ａ
企業の合併や買収をしている事務所でした
私と年が変わらない弁護士が
「新聞の一面に載る仕事をした」という話を
していて とてもキラキラして見えました
私もあんな弁護士になりたい と思って
それからもう一度  一から勉強して
次の年に司法試験に合格をして
弁護士になりました
インターンをした事務所で働きましたが
仕事はとてもやりがいがありました
でも とても忙しくて
12時前に帰れるということは
ありませんでした
でも 仕事で関係があるアメリカに
留学がしたい
と思って 留学の準備を始めました
とても疲れている
仕事が忙しかったこともあったので
留学のための英語の試験に寝坊してしまった
ということも何回もありました
ついに 2008年に
アメリカのロースクールに留学ができました
次の年からは
ニューヨークの法律事務所で働きました
その時に 私の人生を
変える出来事がありました
同じ事務所で働いていた アメリカ人の
男性の弁護士が 育児休暇を取ったのです
当時日本では  私の周りには 男性で
育児休暇を取る という人がいませんでした
男性も育児休暇を取るんだと
大変驚きました
それから調べてみると
日本の女性の５割 ６割の人が
１人目のお子さんを持って
お仕事を辞められていました
女性が 仕事か または子育てか
その二者択一を
迫られている現状でした
私は 女性が 仕事 または子育て
そして 仕事も 子供も 家族も
両方を選べる社会を作りたい
女性が 自由に選択できる社会を
作りたいと思いました
女性が そのように
仕事を辞めている原因は
保育園が足りない ということが
当時 一番の原因でした
保育園を作る権限は  市にあります
自分が好きな大津市に戻って
保育園を作ろう
女性が自由に選択できる社会を作ろう
と思い
選挙に出よう 市長選挙に出よう
ということを思いました
いろんな人に 手紙を書きました
でも 多くの人は
「若すぎる」または
「何の経験もないじゃないか」
ということを言われました
また 自分でも
「苦労して弁護士になったのに
選挙に落ちたら弁護士ができなくなる」
ということも思いました
非常に迷いました
そういった中で ひとつ
友人が言ってくれた言葉があります
それは「世の中には 自分の住む場所や
また 仕事を選べない人がたくさんある」
「迷うということは
選択肢があるということ」
「それは非常にラッキーなことなんだ」
と言ってくれました
それから思う存分
迷うことができました
もう一つ
友人が言ってくれた言葉があります
それは「自分にしかできないことを
するべきだ」という言葉でした
確かに 私がアメリカに行っても
私の代わりをしてくれる弁護士はいました
市長は一人しかいません
そして 若いからこそ
また 経験がないからこそ
女性だからこそ できることが
あるのではないか と思いました
そこで 大津市に戻って
選挙に出ました
2012年に いろんな方の
ご支援を頂いて 市長になりました
当時36歳で 日本で一番若い
女性の市長でした
私は ８年間 市長をしている間に
54園 3,000人分の保育園を作りました
その結果 ４年 年度当初で
待機児童が ゼロになりました
今までは 女性が
30代の女性が
子育てのために仕事をやめるという
Ｍ字カーブというのがありました
これが なくなりました
また 小さいお子さんを持って働く女性が
70％増えました
そして 大津市に引っ越してきてくれる人も
増えました
私は これが自分のゴールだと
いうふうに思って やってきました
女性が仕事を続けられる
しかし 決してそれは
ゴールではありませんでした
会社の中を見ると
女性と男性が同じように働けているか
というと 決してそうではありません
私は今 弁護士の仕事をしながら
女性の 企業の役員を
育成する会社を立ち上げました
今 日本の上場企業の
女性の役員は９％です
経団連は 2030年に女性の役員を
30％にするという目標を掲げています
それには あと8,000人の
女性の役員が足りません
もう一つ  私がこの会社を
立ち上げた理由があります
それは この風景です
これは 私が市長の時に
いつも見ていた風景です
女性は私一人  ということは
決して珍しくありませんでした
市役所の中でも ― 市役所は終身雇用
年功序列 というような組織です ―
その中で 職員の人と話している時に
直接話す職員の方は
やはり 50代後半の男性
ということが多かったです
そういう中で いろんな話をする中で
例えば 机を叩かれたり
また ドアを バーンと閉めて出て行かれた
ということもありました
当時は「私が若いからだ」
また「女性だからじゃないか」
ということを 思っていました
でも 本当の原因は
そうではなかったんです
本当の原因は
私が言っていたことが
それまでの市役所のやり方や
考え方と違ったからです
私は 子育てにお金を使う
ということを言ってました
一方で 人口が減り始める中で
市の予算は どんどん厳しくなっています
お金を削るところは
人口減少に合わせて 削るところは削る
そして その分のお金を 子どもに回す
ということを言っていました
しかし これまで大津市でも日本でも
人口が増えてくる中で
施設をつくり そして
いろんな補助金を増やしていく
これが市役所の仕事でした
私が言っていたことは これまでの
市役所のやり方に 合いませんでした
でも 外の世界は変わっています
少子高齢化が進み 人口が減る
その中で やり方を
変えていかなければなりません
ずっと組織の中にいると
外の世界が見えなくなる
そのことの怖さを感じました
でも これは 決して 市役所の中でだけ
起こっていることではありません
日本企業も同じような 終身雇用 年功序列
といったような組織があります
そういう中で なかなか日本企業が変われない
イノベーションが起こらない
その一つの原因は
意思決定が多様化していない
というところにあると思っています
ですので 女性だけではなく 若い方や
外国人の方や いろんな方が意思決定に加わる
それが 大事なことだと思っています
そのことが日本経済 日本の成長につながる
というふうに信じています
これまでの私の人生を振り返ってみると
客観的に見れば 皆さんから見れば
大変そうだなと
見えることもあったかもしれません
でも 私自身は やめたいと
思ったことは 一度もありません
それは 迷いに迷って
本当に自分がやりたいこと
そして 自分にしかできないことを
見つけられたからだと思っています
本当に自分がやりたいことが見つかれば
その後のどんな困難も
乗り越えていけると信じています
ぜひ皆さんも
皆さん一人一人が
自分にしかできないことを
探してください
（拍手）